I think that is naive to think that we
will get soon to a point where we don't
buy stuff I know someone who's a
freaking she lives in a community in
portland ore in oregon somewhere near
portland were there a lot of other
freegans she's in her 20s she doesn't
have a family she doesn't have a job she
you know dumpster dives for food she
doesn't take a car she will walk or ride
a bike it's a wonderful in terms of her
personal impact on the planet is great
but for the rest of us who buy stuff who
have families we don't have that option
so rather than a post consumer society
it's exactly what you said we need a
smart consumer society and now we have
the data our finger tips that will help
us do just that
what you assuming is that it's more
expensive for the better product and
that's an easy assumption most of us
would think so and in fact the marketing
has been such that we have come to
expect that the premium product will be
the better product including an eco in
the eco realm actually if you look at
skin deep and you look at the 10 safest
shampoos and the 10 war shampoos the
single most expensive shampoo is among
the 10 worst so it doesn't really equate
also as consumer shifts drive companies
to upgrade the supply chain businesses
know how to make things cheaper even
better things cheaper one of the biggest
players in this by the way is Walmart
Walmart is using life cycle assessment
to look at all of its house brands it
has four thousand seven hundred plus
house brands tens of thousands of
suppliers it is going to ask their its
suppliers to upgrade their ecological
impacts once they once Walmart gets into
the game you're going to find huge
economies of scale in this very area so
there may be higher price for some of
this now but I don't think it'll be that
way in the loan I also think by the way
in terms of the present economy that
this may be finding innovating the
better alternative product may be the
one of the biggest entrepreneurial
opportunities for decades now and coming
out of the slump I think that though
this may be one thing that drives a
recovery in fact
well I think the the bottom line is that
we can make the bottom line drive the
planet in a better direction if we each
take responsible I mean if we chip us
simply went to good guide com took out
the 10 thing a list of the 10 things we
buy most often every week looked at them
and see if they're the best alternative
or if there's a better one we can get
and did that and then told our friends
why we had done what we done put on
facebook or you know your email is
whatever and do something else email the
company good guide gives you the option
in a single click to inform the company
whose product you have bought or not
bought why you made that decision the
more of us that do that the stronger we
will have leverage and the sooner to get
companies to change how they do things
so I think that all of us have a new
kind of collective power I'm actually
quite hopeful